nos encontramos con Alexander camichin
que es el ceo de la red ferroviaria de
Ucrania una organización que ha sido
esencial en la supervivencia de este
país durante el último año desde el
primer día de la invasión a escala
completa el 24 de febrero y para empezar
Le quiero preguntar cómo en un país en
guerra la mayor prioridad de los trenes
de Ucrania es que haya puntualidad Cómo
se logra eso de hecho es fácil no hay
secretos no hay nada detrás
sabemos que durante la Guerra es
importante para nuestra gente poder
confiar en algo
y los ferrocarriles es algo de lo que
pueden confiar saben que ningún tren se
ha cancelado saben que intentamos estar
a tiempo y por eso es que se sienten
seguros porque confían en nosotros y
saben que somos un socio seguro
usted lo hace ver bastante simple Pero
la realidad es mucho más compleja que
esa usted tiene miles de hombres en su
compañía tiene miles y miles de
kilómetros de líneas ferroviarias de
trenes de vagones Y cómo coordinar
primero para que funcionen y todos
lleguen a tiempo y segundo para mantener
la motivación de esas personas que
trabajan con usted en estas
circunstancias tan complicadas
Somos la compañía más grande del país
tenemos 231,000 personas en la compañía
pero esta gente es gente de hierro
estamos trabajando como un equipo como
un sistema
de nuevo es fácil todos saben que
tenemos que seguir rodando todos saben
que tenemos que estar a tiempo todos
saben que tenemos que estar
constantemente arreglando los daños y
regresando las operaciones
si tiene que manejarse correctamente Y
sí es manejado correctamente y seguimos
rodando
usted lo hace sonar bastante simple por
la realidad es mucho más compleja que
esa es una compañía inmensa con miles de
personas que trabajan en ella con
kilómetros y kilómetros de vía
ferroviaria con estaciones de tren y
todo tiene que trabajar a la perfección
para que usted cumpla su objetivo que
tanto conocía ustedes esta empresa y que
tanto estaban preparados para una
situación como esta teníamos otra opción
los rusos vinieron y empezaron a matar a
mi gente
teníamos que pararnos y hacer nuestro
trabajo de manera correcta No pensé en
que si aprendía rápido que se aprendía
despacio en este caso usted va y hace lo
que tiene que hacer y qué hizo hicimos
evacuaciones
cuatro millones de personas evacuadas
dentro del país
incluido un millón de niños
evacuamos 120.000 mascotas incluido un
cocodrilo
evacuamos 600.000 personas desde Ucrania
los países vecinos
al interior cientos de miles de kilos de
ayuda humanitaria
e hicimos que mi país viera como los
cargamentos de exportaciones crecían
Porque esa es la sangre para la economía
Así que hicimos todo lo que teníamos que
hacer usted también trajo decenas de
líderes mundiales hasta kiev el último
en llegar fue tal vez el hombre más
importante y más cuidado del mundo que
es el presidente
ustedes incluyó a su gente y a sus
conductores de trenes y a toda la gente
que trabaja con usted lo trajeron desde
Polonia y lo volvieron a llevar duró 20
horas montado en un tren ha sido esta
una de las misiones más difíciles de
todo este año los llamamos el programa
de acero diplomático Bueno cuando
traemos líderes del mundo Ucrania y los
llevamos de regreso por tren
hemos tenido hasta ahora cerca de 300
delegaciones como este
de hecho algunos días atrás trajimos al
presidente biden a kiev y los llevamos
de regreso y fue un privilegio y un
honor para nosotros manejar esta
situación de la manera correcta
fue una misión complicada
pero lo hicimos de manera precisa
es complicada pero Cuáles han sido otras
de esas misiones complicadas que ha
tenido yo cuatro millones de ucranianos
valoramos a cada persona que realmente
son importantes para nosotros
definitivamente traer y sacar al
presidente vaiden fue un poco más
complicado
para nosotros nos preocupa cada una de
las personas que tenemos los que vivimos
por fuera de Ucrania no nos enteramos
Pero la realidad es que las líneas de
trenes son atacadas sistemáticamente por
las fuerzas rusas entiendo que hasta
septiembre las consecuencias económicas
de esos ataques en las redes
ferroviarias era 4.3 billones de dólares
para empezar Cómo se financia la
restauración de esas redes ferroviarias
importantes como hablábamos Al principio
para la supervivencia de Ucrania viene
de apoyo europeo occidental o viene del
gobierno ucraniano Y también cómo se
logra gestionar para a pesar de sus
ataques
mantenerlas operando
hemos tenido 12.000 años en la
estructura ferroviaria
nos atacan en el día y en la noche pero
nosotros no reportamos los ataques
diarios
vamos y vemos Cómo podemos reparar la
carrilera el puente la estación y volver
a la operación porque a nuestra gente no
le importa lo que sea quebrado y se ha
dañado
a ellos les importa ir en el tren y
viajar a donde tienen que hacerlo
y eso es lo que hacemos
todo este trabajo que ustedes han hecho
ha mantenido la moral de los ucranianos
bastante en alto su trabajo también es
mantener esa moral viva
usted puede decir que nuestra moral
empieza por nuestro presidente zelensky
que se ha sostenido gracias al ejército
nosotros de los ferrocarriles
cada simple ucraniano Se ha sostenido en
su frente de batallas
por eso es que la gente dice que los
ucranianos son resistentes usted ha
llamado que su gente es el segundo
ejército de Ucrania lo tiene repartido
en todas las partes del país incluso
muchos de ellos quedaron en territorio
ocupado usted está basado en kiev lo
hemos visto viajar alrededor de todo el
país pero cómo lograr esa coordinación
en un país realmente en guerra muchas
veces hay dificultades de comunicaciones
por internet muchas veces hay problemas
eléctricos cada uno tiene problemas
familiares Cómo ha sido esa relación
usted con su gente para mantenerla
activa operando Y motivada de nuevo no
hay secreto ni magia detrás
son simples habilidades de gestión usted
descubre que se tiene que hacer y vamos
y coordinamos todo para que se haga de
hecho hemos perdido 344 trabajadores de
los servicios de ferrocarriles últimos
788 hombres de los trenes que han
quedado heridos
y este es el precio Más alto que hemos
pagado en esta guerra tenemos 9.200
trabajadores hombres y mujeres que están
peleando en el ejército pero el resto de
trabajadores ferroviarios que permanecen
en la compañía siguen haciendo su
trabajo
no nos quejamos de que no tenemos
suficiente gente o suficiente dinero u
otras cosas tenemos de todo suficiente y
vamos a continuar sosteniéndonos Vamos a
continuar reparando y vamos a continuar
rodando hablábamos antes de que usted
solamente llevaba seis meses en este
cargo cuando comienza la guerra
Generalmente esto es un poco tiempo para
conocer una empresa tan grande
especialmente como esta a su interior
Isabel realmente cómo funciona y Cómo
opera qué tan preparado estaba usted que
tanto conocía de esta empresa o que
tanto aprendió en el camino
Vengo del mundo privado del manejo de la
inversión bancaria
y el mundo de los trenes era nuevo para
mí pero como dije los rusos no me
preguntaron si estaba listo y no ellos
llegaron con la invasión y tuvimos que
estar firmes
así que no pienso que uno pueda aprender
a estar listo para la guerra de esa
manera
es más fácil si finalmente toma
responsabilidad y se sostiene o no
el papel social como dice es algo que no
se aprende en la universidad o se
adquiere del trabajo anterior como
experiencia
es algo que usted necesita hacer porque
su país lo necesita
yo todo mi equipo el equipo de los
ferrocarriles está listo para hacerlo y
lo hacemos leían un artículo que la
noche antes de la invasión el 23 de
febrero usted tomó una foto de sus hijos
y lo mismo hizo su segundo Y la mandaron
esta foto como señal de tranquilidad a
todos los empleados de la compañía pero
la realidad es qué tan preparados
ustedes estaban para esta invasión la
estaban esperando
antes del comienzo nos estábamos
preparando para la guerra Claro porque
muchos expertos extranjeros nos dijeron
que la guerra vendría pero no
esperábamos una guerra civil
una invasión a escala completa con
bombardeos ataques aéreos con tanques
definitivamente ni yo ni mi gente ni la
compañía el país no estaba listo para
esta clase de guerra
de hecho la noche antes de la guerra
estaba en la casa con mis hijos
fue una sorpresa para mí cuando la
invasión comenzó el 24 en la mañana
tuve que dejar a mi familia e ir a hacer
mi trabajo hacer mi servicio en la
compañía
la siguiente vez que vi a mi familia fue
unos meses después del comienzo de la
guerra
solo por un día
de hecho todo el país mostró una alta
resistencia
mis chicos mis hijos mostraron una gran
resistencia no me vieron Durante los
primeros meses pero se comportaron
correctamente e hicieron lo que un
hombre de verdad debe hacer
no tuve ningún dolor de cabeza con ellos
me enfoqué en mi trabajo que es hacer
que los trenes sigan
y mis hijos como el resto de Ucrania
demostraron que podemos resistir que
resistimos posiblemente sea una pregunta
que le han hecho bastantes veces pero
Cuál ha sido el momento más duro de esta
guerra que seguramente ha tenido
momentos bastante bastante difíciles
el más difícil fue el primer día de la
guerra
cuando no se puede creer que esto
realmente puede pasar en la vida real
en El Siglo 21 dentro de Europa
Bad pero una vez que reconocimos que
había pasado fue más fácil
uno sabe qué tiene que hacer y va y lo
hace
los trenes también han jugado un papel
fundamental a nivel militar ustedes no
tienen armas en sus manos pero han
jugado un papel estratégico por un lado
trayendo esas armas dadas por occidente
hacia el interior de Ucrania pero
también en el momento en que los pueblos
que han sido tomados por Rusia y luego
son retomados ustedes van y restablecen
esas líneas ferroviarias restablecen
esos cruces y les quitan el poder a los
rusos de seguir usando esas líneas para
abastecer sus líneas militares para la
logística y eso De por sí es una gran
Victoria para Ucrania Así que cuál es
realmente ese papel militar que están
jugando ustedes en esta guerra somos una
compañía civil
los intereses civiles son muy
importantes para nosotros
tenemos una orden del presidente y el
Primer Ministro curacof de restaurar las
redes ferroviarias en los territorios
que han sido retomados tan pronto como
nuestro ejército recupera el territorio
hasta ahora hemos recuperado las
conexiones con todas las áreas retomadas
era muy importante para nosotros hacerlo
Tan pronto como fuera posible los trenes
dan vida de nuevo a las ciudades
primero da libertad de viajar segundo
permite la llegada de ayuda humanitaria
tercero permite las exportaciones de
cargamentos los negocios regresan a los
territorios retomados la gente empieza a
moverse pagar impuestos y activar la
economía
por eso es que somos muy apasionados con
la labor de restablecer el servicio de
trenes en la ciudad de retomadas apenas
es posible en los últimos meses el
presidente Putin ha lanzado una gran
campaña de contra la infraestructura
eléctrica y eso afectado directamente a
su compañía porque entiendo que muchos
de los trenes
funcionan con energía eléctrica
cuando atacan infraestructura eléctrica
y quedamos desconectados del suministro
eléctrico encontramos la manera de cómo
cambiar lockers electrónicos con
dislockers y seguir rodando
no cancelamos a ningún pasajero del
servicio de trenes por ataques o cortes
eléctricos
Aunque finalmente es complicado
Imagínese que su tren se detiene en el
medio de la nada
Usted tiene que encontrar el dislocker
más cercano
poner a su equipo en el Locker traerlo
hasta el tren y mover el trenza
es complicado pero aprendimos a hacerlo
de manera eficiente y ahora lo hacemos
Cómo se ve usted dentro de un año
para mí este trabajo no es cualquier
trabajo
estoy sirviendo a mi país a mi compañía
por el tiempo en el que el presidente y
el vicepresidente me necesiten en esta
posición
una vez haya terminado podré pasar
tiempo con mis hijos con mi familia
tener algo de tiempo
hace un año complicado hablando con
muchos ucranianos piensan que este no es
el momento de negociar porque el
presidente Putin podría tomar ventaja
descansar
reabastecerse reestructurar su ejército
y volver a relanzar una invasión usted
que piensa de esto la guerra puede
terminar solo con la victoria
estoy listo para resistir por el tiempo
que me necesiten mientras llega la
victoria y nos estamos acercando a la
victoria nosotros estamos jugando un
papel muy importante para que esa
Victoria se dé más rápido Muchísimas
gracias por estar con Franz 24 en
español
[Música]